من العربيه لكم كل التحيه هذه نشره
الخامسه وانا ريما مكتبي نبدا بابرز
العناوين
الاتحاد النقل الجويه الدولي ينتقدوا عوده
قيود كورونا في المطارات ويقول التجربه
اثبتت فشلها
مجلس النواب ينعقد مجددا لانتخابي خلفا
للتلوزي والجمهوري يسعى لتجاوز انقسام
حسبه
في اول خطابات العام في تهدئه غضب
النقابات
اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا بدا الاستعدادات لاستقبال
انظمه صواريخ بيتريات المضاده للطائرات من
الولايات المتحده وقال كوليبا ان اوكرانيا
تتوقعوا نشر هذه الانظمه في اقرب وقت
مضيفا ان الجهود جاريه بشكل مكثف لايجاد
حلول جديده فيما يتعلق بتوريد انواع جديده
من الاسلحه الغربيه كليب اشار الى ان
اوكرانيا طلبت في المقام الاول دبابات
غربيه متطوره وعربات ومدرعات او عربات
[موسيقى]
خطاب لي ريشي سوناك رئيس الحكومه
البريطانيه اول خطاب هذا العام نستمع
لميسالتين
وفي بالي الجميع
والاشخاص قلقون عندما يرى سيارته الاسعاف
كلها في ابواب المستشفيات لكم ان تعرفوا
باننا نتصرف بشكل طار وزيادتي ساعات
الاسره باضافه 7000 سرير اضافيه
العامه هي المجتمع والتفريق الاسره
الصحه تعمل
خطط مستقبليه لسيارات الاسعاف وفيما يخص
الاضرابات
هنالك الكثير من المعلومات المغلوطه لذلك
ومن الجميع ان يدرك به موقف الحكومه نحن
نقيم بشكل كبير ام القطاع عامه
يقومون بعمل هام جدا ولهذا السبب نحن نريد
حوارا عقول مع نقابات فيما هو مسؤول ومنصف
لبلادنا وفي الايام المقبله سوف نحدثكم في
ما يخص خطوات الحكومه القادمه اليوم
ان اقدم التزاما بسيطا هذه الحكومه دائما
ستعكس اولويات
الشعبالا من السياسيين الذين يعدون بكل
شيء ويفشلون
الحكومه
واكثر على الاشياء التي تهمهم تكلفه
المعيشه مرتفعات جدا اوقات الانتظار في
دائره الصحه طويله جدا
الهجره غير الشرعيه كثيره وكبيره جدا
اعتقد بانهم يقبلونها ويدركون بان كثير
منها التحديات جزءا هيرتا من الكوب 19
واثار الحرب في اوكرانيا
ولكن هذا ليس بالعذر يجب ان نعالج هذه
المشاكل وليس فقط التحدث عنها ومنذ تولد
منصب رئيس الوزراء حققنا التقدم وهو حقنا
الاستقرار في الاقتصاد وفن المليارات من
الدعم التي تكلفه المعيشه واستثمن
الريالات الاضافيه في المدارس اداره الصحه
العامه
العلاقاتنا حول العالم حول كل شيء من
اوكرانيا الى امن الاقتصادي المشترك
واستمر بدعمنا المستمر للقوات المسلحه
وجهودها المحافظه على امنيه
انعدام العداله للهجره غير القانونيه ولكن
بالتاكيد
يجب ان نفعل المزيد لذلك او ادو ان اقدمها
خمسه وعود لكم اليوم خمسه تعاهدات
لتحقيق اعتبالكم خمسه اسس
نبني عليها مستقبل افضل لاطفالنا واحفادنا
اولا
سوف
نقل ستضخم هذا العام
عبر البلاد ثالثا
سوف نضمن وان ديننا القومي ينخفض لكي
نؤمننا مستقبل الخدمات العامه رابعا
دائره الصحه واوقات الانتظار سوف تتقلص
وسيحصل الجميع على رعايههم بحاجه عليه
اليها اسرع خامسا سوف نمر القوانين
الجديده لوقف القوارب الصغيره
سوف يبعد عنها اذا خمسه وعود وحاضشه
الدين ونخلص اوقات الانتظار ونوقف القوارب
هذه هي اولويات الشعب وهي اولويات حكمتكم
واما ان نحققها او لا بدون حيل وبدون اي
غموض
اما ان نعمله من اجلكم او نعمل سوف نعيد
بناء الثقافيه السياسه عبر العمل او
بدنا نعمل شيئا لذلك اطلب منكم ان تحكموا
علينا حسب الجهود الذين مثلوا والنتائج
التي نحققها
هذه الوعود الخمسه هي اولويات الشعبان
لذلك هي اولوياتي الفوريه ايضا ولكنها الا
ليست حدود طموحات لبلادنا بل هي الاساس
هدفي هواء بناء مستقبل افضل لاطفالنا
واحفادنا المستقبل
في التذكير السياسيين يتحدثون كثيرا على
التغيير ولكن الحقيقه هي ان لا حكومه ولا
رئيس وزراء بامكاني تغيير البلاد
الاراده او فقط بالكلام التغيير الحقيقي
لا يوفر لا يمنح بل يطالب به ولا يمنح بل
يبتكر
الخيارات
افراد كعمال اصحاب شركه واعمال كلها
تصل الى مرحله عمقه بكثير وان كنا صادقين
فالتغيير ايضا يتطلب التضحيه
والعمل الجاد
خطر كبير ليسيا ان يقول ذلك ولكن المخاطر
عاليه جدا
والمكافاه عاليه وكبيره ولذلك يجب ان يكون
صالحين معكم فالتغيير صعب ويستغرق الوقت
ولكنه ممكن ونحن نعرف ذلك لاننا سبق وان
حققنا ذلك خلال كوبا قمنا بحمايته ملايين
الوظائف والاعمال وهذا الشيء انا افخر به
وانا اعرف ان ذلك ممكن
تغيير وتشعرون
الى المدارس
التي تنتج افضل النتائج هؤلاء المعلمون
والطلبه يعملون بايجاد ويقدمون التضحيات
لانهم يعرفون بان ما يقومون به اكبر من
مجرد انفسهم هم
صبايا يطالبون ويلهمون ويقدمون التميز
وهذا الا التميز يمكن ان يصبح هو الروحيه
روحيه امتي
الامين بهم معا نستطيع ان نغير شخصيه
بلادنا
والنعكسه درجات القبول لخطابل للحجار
ورفض القيودي على طموحاتنا ومن اجل فعل
ذلك
فيجب ان يكون لدينا الخيال والثقه لفعل
الاشياء بشكل مختلف وافضل ان رؤيه
المطلوبه اليوم اللي ما هو مطلوب في
المستقبل بكلمات اخرى يجب ان يغير اسلوب
عمل بلادنا وهذا يتطلب تغيير في العقليات
ما معنى ذلك على ارض الواقع هو يعني
اقتصاد ابتكاريا اكبر ومجتماعات اقوى
وشوارعها
وتعليم بمستوى عالي ودار الصحه مبنيه على
المرضى ومجتمع
يقيموا بها حق قيام العائله وفي كل هذه
المجالات وغيره يجب ان يتحلى بالشجاعه
للتغيير
ولا نستسلم عندما تصعب الامور واذا ما
تمكننا من فعل ذلك
فبمكائنا بحق بناء مستقبل افضل في الاشهر
القادمه سيحدث خططنا في كل هذه المجالات
ولكن اسمحوا لي نوضح المسار اليوم
مستقبل افضل هو اقتصادنا فيه ينمو بشكل
اسرع لكي يتمكن الجميع في كافه انحاء
بلادنا يحصل على فرص جديده من اجل مرتبات
ووظائف افضل والتغيير
في قلب كل شيء وقلب به هو مجسدا بالعديد
من الشركات
واشياء جميله عليها
ولكن هذا هذه هي العقليه بالذات التي يجب
ان نغيرها يسمحوا لي ان اقول لكم لماذا
الابتكار مهم للغايه عبر 50 عاما الماضيه
كانت مسؤوله عن حوالي
زياده انتاجيه بريطانيا
ازدادت عن طريق الابتكار والتكلفه المنت
ولا خدمات خفضت بربتيكار والتحديات الكبرى
مثل امن الطاقه والصافيه
هذا الخطاب الاول لهذا العام في وقت تخوض
بريطانيا اصعب مراحلها الاقتصاديه
والماليه والاضرابات العامه تشل البلاد
تحدث عن خطه من خمس نقاط
لتقليس التضخم وايضا تنميه الاقتصاد
وتنميه المؤسسات العامه والانيك اس اي
خدمه صحه الوطنيه
غير الشرعيه وهي سياسه الهجره التي
تعتمدها الحكومه الحاليه نبحث بتفاصيل هذا
الخطاب مع مراسل العربيه من لندن مصطفى
زارو مصطفى اهلا بك يعني
كل رئيس حكومه السلام وعد بتغيير باقل له
يعني ابرد نقطه يا دائما انا خدمات الصحه
الوطنيه هل من جديد بالنقاط الخمس التي
طرحها ريشي سوناك
اولا ابدا بهذا الخطاب المتفائل لعام
2023 يريد ان يحفز الناس وان يغير نظرتهم
السلبي التي عاشها الجميع يعني ليس فقط في
هذا البلد بل بل في مختلف العالم ولكن
بالنسبه للمواطنين البريطانيين كان هناك
يعني اخبار سيئه سلبيه همم وظائف همم
مشاكل في الوظائف في الاقتصاد والتضخم هذه
هذه هي ال- ال- يعني النظره السريعه
الاولى على خطاب رئيس هناك المتفائل ولكن
سيواجه التحديات في في محاوله ايجاد حلول
لمشاكل جمع حول
النقطه الاولى التي تحدث عنها من النقاطات
الخمسيه تقليص تضخم كيف يمكن ذلك من دون
اعطاء اي تنازلات للنقابات
يجب التذكير ريما وانت تعرفين بان من
اولويات ريش سوناك خلال حملته الانتخابيه
ليصبح رئيس وزراء قال بانه يريد ان يسيطر
على التضخم التضخم هو المصدر قلق الجميع
ليس في هذه البلاد في جميع انحاء العالم
وبالتالي لا يريد ان يضيف الى مساله
التضخم لتزيد التكاليف المعيشه اكثر من ما
هي عليه حاليا وبالتالي ربما هو مصر ان
يسيطر على التضخم اولا وبالتالي يريد ان
يعالج التحديات الاخرى لا سيما في قطاع
الصحه التي نعرف بان قوائم انتظار يعني
التزيد عن سبعه ملايين مريض ينتظرون
لاجراء عمليه روتينيه وبالتالي هذا تحدي
كبير يريد ان همم
ينشئ ربما هناك لجنه ستنظر الى كيفيه
تقليص هذه
القوائم الانتظار بالاضافه الى همم ايجاد
كوادر طبيه لملئ الوظائف بالتالي تعب
كبيره وتحديات اقتصاديه كبيره تواجه ريس
سوناك خصوصا وان اقل من يعني تقريبا سنه
امامه لحل هذه المشاكل قبل الانتخابات
العامه قال نريد تخفيض الضرائب على الطبقه
العامله
في خبر عاجل هلا على الوكالات همم لا
سياسه في تغيير ضرائب صح يعني لا يعني
تراجعت الحكومه اصلا قبل هيك عن همم
الموضوع على الضرائب لا تخفيض في الضرائب
ام انه سيعلن تخفيض جديد
حقيقه يعني مشكله مساله الضرائب سيدنا ما
حصل خلال فتره همم ليستراس وكان هو من اشد
المؤيدين للسيطره على التضخم وايضا خفض
الضرائب ياتي في وقت ما عندما يكون الظروف
الاقتصاديه تسمح بذلك وبالتالي لن اتوقع
تخفيضات ضريبيه قريبا ربما ستكون بعض
المساعدات لشركات مثل ما شهيدنا فيما
يتعلق همم بفواتير الطاقه ايضا همم الان
اصبح بالامكان لشركات ان تستفيد من هذا
الدعم الحكومي ولكن سيكون محدود جدا هكذا
يعني همم
الشركات وبالتالي تخفيض الضرائب ربما غير
مطروح حاليا يعني انا وانت غطينا سقوط
حكومات ب 2022 ما بعرف اذا 2023 سيكون
اكثر هدوءا اقل له بالنسبه
مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
في غضون ذلك قال المتحدث باسمي وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان استخدام الجنود الروس
لهواتفهم النقاله في مدينه مكيفكا في شرق
اوكرانيا هو سبب الرئيس للضربه الصاروخيه
الاوكرانيه التي استهدفتهم ليله راس السنه
وعدد بحياه 89 شخصا بحسب وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
رباط الكنيسه
حديثه لكن من الواضح بالفعل ان السبب
الرئيسي لما حدث هو الاستخدام المكثف من
قبل افراد الفوز للهواتف المحموله ما
جعلهم في متناول اسلحه العدو وسامح هذا
للعدو بتحديد احداثيات مواقع الافراد
العسكريين لشد الضربه الصاروخيه يتم حاليا
ماساويه ممثله في المستقبل نتيجه للتحقيق
سيتم تقديم المسؤولين المذنبين الى
العداله
ينضم اليه من دوناتس مراسل العربيه رائد
الاخضر ومن موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد ابدا من عبد الجواد من
بديهيات المعارك حتى نحن الصحفيين نعرفها
عندما تكون على الجبهه الاماميه عمليه رصد
الهواتف النقاله سهله جدا بالنسبه للانظمه
بالنظم المتطوره التكنولوجيه لماذا فتح
الجنود الروس هواتفهم على الجبهه الاماميه
ما تقولين ان الخط الاول للمواجهه حتى
الخط الثاني يمنع جميع من يتواجد في
المنطقه باستخدام يعني هاتفه المحمول لان
الخطر يشمل الجميع ولا يشمل الشخص الممسك
لهاتفه المحمول عند تواجده في تلك النقاط
الخطره نوعا ما للصحفيين او لغيرهم لكن
طبعا روايه موسكو اليوم تتحدث عن ان خطا
فادحا كبيرا كما يرون حدث ليله راس السنه
عندما تم السماح او عندما قام الجنود
المتواجدين في تلك المنطقه وهم عديمو
الخبره بالاعمال القتاليه باعتبارهم
باعتبارهم من تلك الفئه التي تم تعبئتهم
خلال الفتره الماضيه لدعم موسكو على خط
المواجهه مع اجانب الاوكراني لكن طبعا هذه
الروايه ريما لم تعجب كثيرين في البلاد
البعض راح يتحدث عن ان يعني همم اعمده
الاستقبال في تلك المنطقه هي تخضع للشبكات
الروسيه ولا مدخل للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
لمعرفه وتحديد احداثيات او اماكن تواجد
الجنود طبعا البعض راح يتحدث عن ان
الاقمار الصناعيه زودت هذه الاحداثيات
ونقطه اخيره لو سمحت
البعض يتحدث عن ان هناك من قام باصال
الاحداثيات الى الجانب الاخراني
هنا سؤال ينتقل الى دوناتس كما مراسل
العربيه رائد الاخبار رائد هل تملك
اوكرانيا هذه التقنيات اما ان هناك اجهزه
غربيه تساعدها لانه عمليه رصد الهواتف
النقاله سهله وليست سهله يعني هي عمليه
مكلفه ايضا اييه هل الاجهزه الغربيه تساعد
الاوكران في هذه الحاله
تحدثت الدفاع الروسيه باستمرار وموسكو
قالت بان الاستخبارات البريطانيه
والامريكيه هي التي تعمل اضافه الى
الاسلحه المتطوره التي تقدمها همم القوات
الغربيه
يعني الناتو يقدم اسلحه متطوره للجيش
الاوكراني لكن لابد من ان نعرج على
استمرار العمليات العسكريه هنا وارتفاع
وتيره القصف المقاطعه مقاطعه دانيسك بشكل
عام ريما هنا ال 24 ساعه الماضيه اسفرت عن
قتيل وثلاثه اصابات وما زالت المدينه
ساكنه وهناك وعمليه نزوح كبيره من المدينه
الى المناطق الاخرى ذلك بعد الضربه
القاسيه التي وجهها الجيش الاوكراني الى
مركز تجنيد روسي بالفعل هناك عمليه نزوح
كانت الى مدن خرسيس الناحيه الشرقيه وما
كيفكا لكن بعد ضربه مكيف كابات الناس
يخافون من النزوح الى ما كيف كان وباتوا
يذهبون الى مناطق ابعد الاهم من ذلك ان
القصف الروسي هو الاكثر من القصف
الاوكراني نسبه ال يعني القصف الروسي تصل
الى اضعاف تسع مرات القصف الاوكراني ولابد
ان ذلك ينطوي تحت اطار عمليه الرد الروسي
على تلك الضربه القويه قالت وزاره الدفاع
بانها ضربت همم اذا سمحتي قالت وزاره
الدفاع انها ضربت قاعده عسكريه اوكرانيه
قتلت فيها اكثر من 200 جندي اوكراني
وصفتهم بالنازيين والقوميين اضافه الى
المرتزقه الاجانب كما قالت الدفاع الروسيه
ودمرت همم من صواريخ هاي مرزوقه من صواريخ
همم تشيكيه الصنع التي دخلت حديثا في
المعارك كما انها نشهد هنا في هل تسمعين
ريما اسمع
ك لو سمحت ان تنتظر
زميلك من الجهه الروسيه
من موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد انت معي ويبدو
انه خسرنا الاتصال مع رائد عبد الجواد
غرفتك
اوف دخلت حيز التنفيذ هكذا يقول الروس يرد
الاوكران بانه البيتريوت في الطريق اولا
لنبدا بالجهه الروسيه كيف تغير هذه
المعادله همم دخول هكذا قطع عسكريه للحرب
ريما طبعا وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقيه شيكو
اليوم في تقرير قدمه لرئيس البلاد
الظالمين بوتن تحدث عن ان الفرقاطه
الحامله لصواريخ تصيركون وهي صواريخ فرط
صوتيه يمكنها حمل الكثير من يعني الرؤوس
ومنها النوويه ويعني سرعه هذه الصواريخ
تصل الى 9 مرات اسرع من سرعه الصوت ما
يعني انها يمكنها قطع يعني قرابه 10,000
كيلو متر تقريبا في الساعه الواحده طبعا
هذه الصواريخ يمكنها الوصول الى مناطق عده
يعني مسافتها تصل الى اكثر من 1000 كيلو
متر كما يتحدث الجانب الروسي وطبعا اجهزه
الدفاع الجوي واجهزه الدفاع الصاروقي لا
يمكنها استهداف اول وصول الى هذه النوعيه
من هذه الصواريخ طبعا همم مسيره هذه
الفرقه ستكون المحيط الاطلسي المحيط
الهندي وستصل حتى الى البحر الابيض المتوس
هي رساله واضحه من موسكو للغرب كما ترى
القراءه السياسيه في البلاد باعتبار انها
تتزامن مع وصول الباتريوت الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه طبعا هي عمليه جديده لعرض
العضلات باعتبار ان موسكو تتحدث عن عدم
اغنيتها الدخول في حرب نوويه مع الغرب او
مع اي جهه اخرى في المقابل كما يتحدث
الغرب لكن نلاحظ بان الجانبين يتجهان نحو
هذه الخطوه نوعا ما في نقطه اخيره ريما لو
سمحتي
قامت بتجربه لصاروخ هيرسون تفضليما سنعود
الرشاد وايضا كان معي من دونيت مراسل
العربيه الرائد الاخضر شكرا
قال مسؤولون اوكرانيه ان الوقت قد حان
لارسال لقوات حفظ السلام الى محطه
النوويه دون حتى ابرام اتفاق مع روسيا
لاقامه منطقه امنه هناك واوضح رئيس الشركه
الوطنيه للطاقه النوويه في اوكرانيا انا
مفاوضات وكاله الطاقه الذريه لا تحرز اي
تقدم ولا يوجد حل حتى الان يذكر ان محطه
زوريجيا النوويه هي اضخم محطات اوروبا
وتتعرض للقصف والقطاع الكهرباء مرارا مما
اثار مخاوف وقوع الكارثه
فيما تتبادل اوكرانيا وروسيا لاتهامات في
القصر
امر رئيس روسي بلاديمير بوتين بادخال
الفرقه تعبر الغرسكوف المزوده بصواريخ
زيكن فرط الصوتيه للخدمه العسكريه واكد
بوتين ان التسليح القوي للفرقات سيحمي
روسيا من التهديدات الخارجيه واصفا
بالاعمالها بالحدث المهمه بدوره قال وزير
الدفاع روسي سيرجيو ان روسيا ستستخدم
صواريخ زرقا خلال محمد الفرقات
في محيطين الاطلسي والهندي والبحر المتوسط
اود ان اشكر اولا وقبل كل شيء المختصين في
مجمع الصناعات الدفاعيه الذين ابتكروا
وبدؤوا لانتاج الدخل لهذا السلاح الفريد
كما قلت بالفعل لا يوجد مثيل له في اي
دوله في العالم انا متاكد من ان هذا
السلاح القوي سيسمحوا لروسيا بحمايه نفسها
من التهديدات الخارجيه المحتمله بشكل
موثوق وسيساعدنا في خدمه المصالح الوطنيه
لبلدنا
كوريا الجنوبيه تهدد بالغاء اتفاق المنطقه
العازله بعد توهل مسيرات من الشمال
اهلا بكم من جديد انتقد رئيس اكبر هيئه
تجاريه للشركات الطيران في العالم القيود
المفروضه على السفر ضد المسافرين من الصين
بحجه ان مثل هذه التدابير قد ثبت انها غير
فعاله في منع انتشار كورونا المدير العام
الذي اتحاد الدولي للنقل الجوي عيادته عبر
عن اسفه جراء عودته قيود قرون في بعض
المطارات مجددا رغم ثبوت فشل تلك القيود
طيله ثلاث سنوات ماضيه على حددي تعبيره
في هذه الاثناء تواصل الصين مكافحه التفشي
وباء كرونه بعد تخليها عن سياسه صفر كوفيت
التي لا طالما تبعتها حيث اعلنت سلطات
الاربعاء عن خمسه وفيات بسبب الفايروس
مقارنه بثلات وفيات سجلتها الثلاثاء
الماضي مما رفع العدد الرسمي للوفيات الى
نحو خمسه الاف وفاه البيانات الصينيه
اي من عائله واحده ماتوا بالفعل لذلك
املوا ان تخبر الحكومه بامانه ومصداقيه
شعبها وشعوب العالم بما حدث بالفعل هنا
عندما واجه الدول الاخرى انتشار الفيروز
اتخذت اجراء مماثله في عام 2020 و 2021
وعندما تفشل فيروس في الخارج اتخذت الصين
ايضا اجراءات مماثله بما في ذلك تعليق بعض
الرحلات الجويه ربما دفعت كثافه الاجراءات
التي اتخذتها الصين في السابق دول اخرى
لاتخاذ اجراءات اكثر جديه ضد المسافرين
القادمين من الصين لذلك يمكنني ان افهم
هذا النوع من الاشياء
في غضون ذلك قال رئيس الوزراء اليمني
فوميو تشيجا ان بلاده ستلزم القادمين من
الصين باجراء اختبار سلبيه مؤكدا ان
اليابان ستتخذ جميع التدابير ممكنه
لمراقبه حدودها منعا لتفشل الفايروس
اختبار بي سي ار على القادمين من الصين
الى اليابان سنلزمهم بتقديم نتائج اختبار
سلبيه للقادمين عبر رحلات مباشره من الصين
اضافه الى ذلك سنتخذوا جميع التدابير
الممكنه لمراقبه الحدود وسستمر ايضا في
وضع قيود اللازمتي على الرحلات الجويه
الاضافيه من الصين
زومبي
يعقد مسؤوله الصحفي دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
ليوم اجتماعا بشان تنسيق الاستجابه لزياده
حالات الاصابه بفيروس كورونا في الصين قبل
ذلك ايدت الغالبيه العظمى من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي اجراء اختبارات كوفد بشكل منهج
المسافرين القادمين من الصين وفق ما اعلن
ناطق باسم المفوضيه الاوروبيه وهذا
الاجراء هو جزء من توصياتنا اعتمدت خلال
اجتماع لمسؤوليه الصحه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي عقد في بروكسيل امس وبحث الخبراء
ايضا في تدابير اخرى اقتراحتها المفوضيه
الاوروبيه بما في ذلك مطالبه المسافرين
الصينيين بوضع الكمامات وزياده الاختبارات
من اجل تحديد متحولات جديده محتمله
وفرضت العديد من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بما
فيها فرنسا واسبانيا وايطاليا اجراء
اختبار على الوافدين من الصين في انتظار
ان تتواصل الكتله او تتوصل الكتله الى نهج
موحد
من جهتها استنكرت بكين القيود المتزايده
التي تطبقها ايضا الولايات المتحده
واليابان واستراليا
وهددت باتخاذ التدابير مضاده مبنيه على
مبدا المعامله بالمثل
واعتبرت الصين ان قرار دول بفرد قيود على
مواطنها يفتقر الى اساسا علمي بحسب ما
صرحت الخارجيه الصينيه
صحيفه الشعب اليوميه الصينيه الرسميه قالت
ان السلطات ستحقق النصر في نهايه المطاف
رغم مخاوف وقلق عالمي من تفشي الفايروس
معي نور الدين فريدي من بريكسال مراسله
العربيه نور الدين اهلا بك هل من سياسه
موحده للاتحاد الاوروبي تجاه المسافرين
القادمين من الصين هل ممكن ان يكون هناك
قرار واحد
بعد ساعه من الان سيبحثوا الدبلوماسيون
وخبراء الصحه في الدول الاعضاء ال 27
امكانيات التوصل الى اجراءات احترازيه
المشتركه
من صعود المسافر الى الطائره في الصين حتى
الاجراءات الاخرى التي ستليه وصوله او ما
يتعلق بالمطاراتي بمعنى ان هناك همم قبل
الاجتماع الشعور بوجود اغلبيه تساند
مراجعه الفحوصات السلبيات لدى المسافرين
قبل سعودي من الطائره اذا ساعدوا الى
الطائره ومعهم فحوصات السلبيه فانهم
يطالبون بلبس الكماماتيه وعندما تصل
الطائره تحط الطائره في المطارات
الاوروبيه هناك اقتراح يبحث في نزول
ساعتين المقبلتين بان يتم جمع مياه الصرف
الصحي او مياه المياه المستخدمه في
الطائرات الوافده من لماذا لتحليلي سواء
كان ما يتعلق تحليل العينات للبحث عن همم
سلاسل الجينيه
للمتحور او ربما متحورات فيروسيه جديده
هذا اضافه الى همم هناك نوع من الاجراءات
المتنوعه المتعدده بعض الدول التي في
فرنسا لا تقوموا بالاجراء بالفحوصات مثلا
في المطار وانما تترك السائح باعتبار انه
وصل ب همم
بفحص السلبي ثم تقوم باجراءات او فحوصات
عشوائيه بعد وصول الوفد السياحي هذا الامر
يختلف ربما يتم توحيد ذلك في قبول
والايام المقبله
حيثياته صحيه ام سياسيه بعض الشيء ضد
الصين او تجاه الصين يعني هل مسيس الموضوع
الصحي
في الايام الماضيه هدات او هدا المسؤولون
الوضع لاننا لان اوروبا او المدن
الاوروبيه كانت تجتاز اعياد الميلاد
واعياد راس السنه الان الموضوع صحي ولكن
وطمئن اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار في جمله ما
قاله المركز الاوروبي للوقايه
ومراقبه الامراض من ان الفيروسات او
المتحولات الموجوده في الصين هي منتشره
ايضا في اوروبا التطعيم مرتفع نسبيا في في
اوروبا مقارنه الوضع مطمئن في نظري المركز
الاوروبي للوقايه من الامراض الاوروبي
ايضا
شكرا لك من بروكسيل مراسل العربيه نور
الدين شكرا
[موسيقى]
حدد رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
مع كوريا الشماليه اذا استمرت في
الانتهاكات الصاروخيه وقال رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه انه في حال انتهت اراضي بلاده
سيتم تعليق العمل باتفاق الاوبر مع عام
2018 لانشاء مناطق عازله بين البلدين
ودعيون الى انتاج واسع انتاج الواسع نطاق
لمسيرات صغيره
انتقل المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران
روبرت ماليه قمع السلطات للمحتاجين الشباب
وقال في تغريده له انه يتعين على القياده
الايرانيه الاستماع للشباب بدلا من قتلهم
واشاره مالي الى ان شباب الايراني يواجه
عقوبه الاعدام بعد محاكمات سوريه
الحرس الثوري الايراني
اجراءات عقابيه جديده تنتظر ايران حيث
تتصاعد الدعوات الاوروبيه لتصنيف الحرس
الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه فما عزمي
بريطانيا ادراجها لحرس الثوري على قوائم
المنظمات الارهابيه
تتزايد المطالب نفسها في المانيا تحركات
حديثه من برلمانيين المان للضغط على
الحكومه لتصنيف الحرس الثوري كم منظمه
ارهابيه للالتحاق بدول ابرزها امريكا في
هذا السياق
الدعوات المؤيده لهذه الخطوه ترى في
الحارس الثوري دورا مهما في قمع
الاحتجاجات المستمره في ايران وكاجراء
لمعاقبه النظام في ايران على دوره في
الحرب باوكرانيا حضر الحرس الثوري يعني ان
اي انتماء للمجموعه او حضور اجتماعاته او
حمله شعاراته في الاماكن العامه او
التشجيعه على دعم انشطته يعاقب عليها
بالقانون دعوات اخرى تبدا اكثر جديه في
لندن حيث تستعد حكومه
لتصنيف الحارس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه في
غضون اسابيع بعد عشر مؤامرات لخطف او قتل
اشخاص في بريطانيا العمل الماضي وفقا
صحيفه التلغرافيا البريطانيه رشا خياط
العربيه
وتتابعونا في الخامسه ولكن بعد فاصل
المرصد السوري يحمل فصائل امواليه لايران
مسؤوليه استهداف في قاعده التحالف الدوليه
في دير الزور
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد المرصد السوري ان
الفصائل المواليه لايران هي المسؤوله عن
استهداف في قاعده التحالف الدولي في حقل
كونيكول الغاز بريفي دير الزور الشمالي
وكانت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه اعلنت
تعرض قوات التحالف الدولي ضد داعش لهجوم
بصاروخين في شمال شرق سوريا
في سياق اخر اعلن وزير الدفاع التركي
خلوصي اكار امكانيه توسيع وتطوير الدوريات
المشتركه في مع روسيا في الشمال السوري
واضاف ان هذه الخطوه ستكون بناء على
محادثات مباشره مع دمشق واشار خلوسي اكار
الى انقر تعمل في استمرار المفاوضات
الثلاثيه لوزراء دفاع تركيا وروسيا وسوريا
في الفتره المقبله حول الوضع على الحدود
اليوم جلسه لانتخاب رئيس له بعد ثلاث
جولات اقتراع فشلت خلالها الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه امس في حشد الاصوات اللازمه
لانتخاب مرشحها كابل مقاسي رئيسا للمجلس
اخفاق الجمهوريين الذين فازوا بالاغلبيه
في مجلس النواب بعد انتخابات منتصفي
الولايه يعد سابقا لم تحدث منذ 100 عام
ولم يتمكن مقاسي من تهدئه غضبه مجموعه من
مؤيدين رئيس السابق ترامب بنتخابه خلفا
لنانسي فلوسي اذ ان هؤلاء ضلوا على رايهم
بانه معتدل اكثر مما ينبغي ما يعكس حده
الخلافات ما دفعت ترامب لاحقا الى دعوه
الجمهوريين لدعم مكارثيه ويحتاج انتخاب
رئيس للمسجد للمجلس وهو ثالث اهم شخصيه في
المشهد السياسي الامريكي بعد الرئيس وانا
ابيه اغلبيه بنسى 218 صوتا وهي عتبه لم
يتمكن مقاسي من بلوغها
حيث قرر نحو 20 نائبا من مؤيدي ترامب
عرقله انتخابه
وقلمت جايتس ان نائب عن ولايه فلوريدا
كيفن لا يؤمنوا باي شيء وليس لديه
ايديولوجيا ومع ذلك فان الترشح مكرسي يحظى
بتايدا واسع داخل حسبه اذكوا بلا الاعلان
عن ترشحه بتصفيق الحائر وقوفا في صفوف
النواب الجمهوريين
وتعهد الجمهوريون اثر فوزي بالاغلبيه
باستخدام قوتهم التشريعيه لاطلاق السلسله
تحقيقات بشان اداره الرئيس بايزون لكن قبل
ان شنو هذه الحرب يتعاين عليهم الاتفاق
على انتخاب رئيس المجلس
النوابنا
الله بيزنس
واشنطن
[تصفيق]
معنى من واشنطن مراسل العربيه حسين الطوط
حسين اليوم بعد كلام ترامب هل ممكن ان
يتغير اي شيء في المعادله ان يؤثر على
المعارضين لمكرسي
تحيه لك ريما هذا ما ننتظره بعد ساعتين
ونصف من الان عندما ينعقد مجلس النواب
الامريكي لنرى ان كانت دعوه ترامب مؤيديه
بالتصويت لما كارتي ستلقى تجاوبا منهم
بطبيعه الحال ماكارتي البارحه تعاهد ايضا
من دوره بانه سيستمر حتى النهايه للفوز
برئاسه مجلس النواب واشار لانه مستعد
الانتظار ولمح واشار ايضا الى خطاب الطويل
قال انه كان لديه اطول خطاب في مجلس
النواب فهو مستعد للمضيق حتى النهايه
ولكنه في نفس الوقت لما الاحتماليه تخفيض
عتبه الاصوات ال 2008 الى اقل من ذلك شرط
ان همم يلتزم بعد معارضيها الصمت او ان
يصوتوا بحاضر لذلك الان الرجل ريما نستطيع
ان نقول انه في وضع لا يحسد عليه بكل
الكلمه من معنى لانه مطالبه بتقديم
تنازلات اكثر لهذا الجناح اليمين المتشدد
المؤيد لترامب ولكن في الوقت نفسيه قدم
هذه التنازلات سيبتعد عنه المعتدلون
الجمهوري لانه سيرون ان هو ضعيف امام
المتشددين اليمين في الحزب همم ما حدث
البارحه ايضا كان له صدى في مجلس الشيوخ
همم في الكونغرس عندما عبر العديد من
الاعضاء المجلس الجمهوريين البارزين مثل
سون ولدي غرامهم وجون كونين ايضا عن
استغرابهم بما حدثوا عن قلقهم وقالوا اذا
كان الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب لا
يستطيعون ان همم ينتخبوا رئيسا لهم فما
مصير التشريعات التي سيطرحونها في
المستقبل ما جرى البارحه راى فيها
الكثيرون هنا همم ريما همم بدايه همم
لزياده الانقسامات او الخلافات لنقل بين
الجمهوريين لذلك ان لم يستطيع الجمهوريون
اليوم همم تفادي هذه هذه المعذره همم هناك
من يقول اننا مقبلون على الصراع داخل
الحزب الجمهوري اكبر طبعا التصويت سيستمر
لجوله واثنين وثلاثه واربعه عدد جولات
الكافيه حتى يتم انتخاب رئيس اا مجلس
النواب قد استغرق الامر ايام واسابيع او
ربما اشهر كما حدث عام 1855 استمر شهرين
التصويت حتى تم انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب
حتى الان على ما يبدو ان ال 20 نائبا
مصرون على رايهم وقد يتم زياده هذا العدد
لاسيما ان هناك بعض المؤيدين لكبن مكارثي
عبر عن راي بانه اذا لم يكن مقالتي
باستطاعته ان يحصل على المئتين و18 صوتا
فعليه ان يتنازل عن رئاسه همم مجلس النواب
ولكن كما يبدو بحسب تصريحاتنا الكارثه هو
لن يتنازل الان وهو مستمر حتى النهايه
اللي يفوز بهذا المنصب حسين همم هل من
عقلاء داخل حزب الجمهوريين من هي الشخصيات
المؤثره التي ممكن ان همم
ترتب الصفوف الداخليه كلا يظهر الحزب بهذا
الشكل المتشردن
هناك عقلاء كثيرون في داخل الحزب الجمهوري
ولكن عندما نتحدث عن الكونجرس بتاعنا نعرف
ان الكونس هناك مجلس الشيوخ في مجلس
النواب الشخصيه الابرص طبعا الان والمرشح
الاقوى هو كابل مكارتي لديه حلفاء مثل
ستيف اسكارس ولكن حتى حلفاءه هم لم يرشحوا
انفسهم اسكانس هو يدعم مكارثي حتى جيم
جوردن الذي تم ترشيحه البارحه وتم التصويت
عليه ب 20 صوت هو يؤيد مكار في لا يوجد
شخصيه توازي مكارثي بقوتها بقوه حضورها
همم ربما نتحدث عن اسكانس طبعا على الجانب
الاخر مجلس الشيوخ هناك اللي هو زعيم قدير
في الحزب الجمهوري القديم
من يذهب الى همم مجلس الشيوخ الى الكونغرس
ويشاهد هذا الرجل عندما يسير فقط
يستطيع يستطيع ان ان يشعر باهميه هذا
الرجل داخل الحزب الجمهوري ولكن لا لا
اعتقد انه يتدخلون بيفرض رايهم على مجلس
النواب هناك هناك فصل للسل في الولايات
المتحده طبعا سمعنا البارحه انتخابات
كثيره همم كما قلت من لندن من من من الثون
جونسون ولكن متمكن الاباحيه لم يتحدث عن
الموضوع نهائيا وهو شخصيه بارزه طبعا
الشخصيه ال- ال- الاخرى القويه في الحزم
كما نعلم هو دونالد ترامب الذي دعى
الجمهوريين للتصويت لصالح مكارتي شكرا لك
من واشنطن مراسل العربيه
انا اعود والقاكم في نشره المساء شكرا
المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]